[Music]
zebra rope swinging under the opening
credits tells me all I need to know
about how this movie will treat physics
and science and logic okay penguins and
zebras in the same spot that's subject
Dana right there and also unlike
peacocks who everyone knows can fly
penguin are actually flightless birds so
this is someone's fantasy here's some
math for you cartoon physics squared
equals dream cartoon physics the lion
can catch up to the zebra running only
on his back feet it was all a dream
cliche also I guess a treadmill is a
creative way for him to get some
exercise but the Central Park Zoo keeper
is probably experiencing daily fits of
anxiety over the possibility of a random
visit from the representative of the
Zoological Association of America
because all of these enclosures don't
even come remotely close to meeting
their standards dreaming the zoo was
apparently designed on a decommissioned
mini golf course where they just
installed a few 3-foot fences and
decided that was enough hoof mil is
there a whole line of athletic equipment
for animals in this universe it is a
giant class ball that is a very good
question
why not hide something say in your mean
shelf yeah then where the fuck did he
get it even in this universe he's still
just a lion it's not like the Central
Park Zoo merchandising department is
running product by him for his approval
I guess security is so lacks at the zoo
that all the animals are able to easily
escape their enclosures and basically
roam free
allowing Alex to waltz into the gift
shop and take whatever he wants also
based on this picture
alex has pretties in handwriting for a
lion who has paws slash hand hybrids
they're still better than regular paws
but one would assume that he would still
have a disadvantage also there is a
putter which further supports Maya the
zoo used to be a mini golf course theory
none of the people in all of these
apartments back here noticed the line
and Seabrook casually acting like
friends the zoo is a terribly unsafe and
unsecure lion enclosure did that giraffe
just use the toilet um up into the
Central Park Zoo and it looks nothing
like this but whatever cartoon I guess
this monkey fishes out coffee a
newspaper and a bagel without even
looking down at the trash can this
speaks either to the hyper intelligence
of this monkey or the extreme
predictable Ness of the general American
Zoo visiting public also the zoo just
opened so if the janitor didn't empty
the trash last night
nice job dude this is such a random
brain and shout-out I wonder if ziploc
helped underwrite this movie no this
lion display is the lion standing on two
feet on a pedestal posing surrounded by
firework
that's actually incredible I can't tell
is that blue steel given the context
it's probably leti group and I wish the
animals at my local zoo did cool stuff
like this they mostly hi which is why
standard zoo visit for me is basically I
spot sexy hippo ripoff from Fantasia ad
plus one more sin for making me write
the word sexy hippo after this picture
was taken I bet that MRI tech said to
the photographer excuse me but there
should be no electronic equipment near
the MRI and the photographer replied but
it's outside sitting in the grass that
can't be good for teether then the
technician laughs slightly snaps his
neck and drags him off we've broke in
our last show
they've tunnel through concrete with a
common plastic spoon just give them
their freedom they can get no movie
devotes too many seconds to fart noises
there is no visible reason Marty is able
to hold anything he's definitely passed
mr. ed on the anthropomorphism of
echelons kale but he's clearly not at
the Bojack horseman level of being able
to hold stuff what continent is
Manhattan even zebra New Yorkers think
that they are so important that their
island qualifies as a continent I hope
that person who threw that underwears
from another country and his only
exposure to American culture was a Tom
Jones concert he once went to and he is
under the impression that Americans just
throw underwear at anyone who was
receiving praise so each channel gets a
personalized meal served by their own
separate chefs and displayed on a
literal silver platter made in their
image how much is admission to this
fucking Zoo did he not get an actual
dinner like the rest of them the zoo may
be actively trying to kill this giraffe
are we sure this isn't the Copenhagen
zoo a monkey like their colleagues at
the zoo it's not just the Penguins all
the animals here are racist thing you
ever thought there might be more than
life and steak Alex Alex temporarily
forgets what steak was called instead of
giant steak as big as a lions head there
is this a weirdly small lion I'm feeding
him all the stuff Marty just spelled out
literally seconds ago is what's eating
it but later it will be Alex not gonna
find a star like that in the wild
helicopter this helicopter appears out
of nowhere and it's stationary until
Marty says what it is maybe this is one
of san andreas as magical helicopters
that can do impossible things do they
all have their own light switches clap
on heater
Marty turned off the ambience with a
reverse Fonzie why is zebra the only zoo
inhabitant with tons of light on him
during this pull back shot you suck your
thumb
better question you have thumbs you know
how I have that bladder infection and I
have to get up every two hours well you
know how I have a giant bruise on my
hand from you beating me with the fact
that Melman is debilitating Leo I've
been trying to
avoid commenting on the way these
characters look because they're clearly
stylized and I don't find anything wrong
with that really I don't but melman's
neck is too far from actual giraffe
Anatomy I feel like I'm looking at a
giraffe who has broken his neck maybe
that's why he's so sick all the time
she's not just the hippo she's the sassy
black hippo friend Saturday Night Fever
existed that's the whole joke it
wouldn't surprise me if Gloria was in
the next Avengers movie maybe she can
take over for Hawkeye Kaka aunt's
constipation let's just go ahead and add
seven sins for every other terrible poop
and pee joke in the movie if you have
any poo against gas wipe yourself with a
leaf it's not on the train zebra finds
the only time Rockefeller Center skating
rink is empty but still lit up like it's
open if it wasn't a cartoon I'd make
this two sins finally some people see
these fuckin animals sadly it's too late
to keep the plot from happening America
that depends on if it's a white zebra
with black stripes or a black zebra with
white stripes its grand and it's central
and it's a station how invested in the
physics of this cartoon should I be I
thought only the animals were
stereotypical cartoons and their
abilities but here we have an old lady
with super-strength you know what would
make this funnier if he had a giant claw
oh he does great several large and
potentially deadly animals have escaped
from the zoo and they send in the entire
NYPD the fire department and just the
most frightened guy from Animal Control
so are they in reality on all fours just
roaring and they just think they're
standing upright or did the humans
notice that they're staying you know
what animated movie with ambiguously
defined rules in Madagascar four we
learned that alex is addicted to
tranquilizers and has forever been
chasing his first high the boxes become
conveniently lit when each animal starts
talking I have an appointment with dr.
Goldberg at 5:00 the stock paranoid
nebbish character provided by David
Schwimmer presumably they didn't want
what he allen anywhere near a children's
movie this movie expects me to believe
that they ship animals in Ark of the
Covenant crates
some on earth penguins x 4 equals Liam
Neeson person can't hear anything
because they're wearing headphones
cliche why are they going all the way
around Africa wouldn't be faster to just
use the Suez Canal and come from the
north I'm actually curious
many sailors in the house okay they fell
off the ship right at Madagascar okay
fine but only there four crates fell off
the ship right here seriously that's
implausible as hell
somehow after being tossed by all these
waves Alex's box still has no water in
it I mean he should be dead at the ocean
floor at this point no DreamWorks has an
unhealthy obsession with putting large
quantities of things in its characters
mouths Alex doesn't think to pull him
out by his feet thus manufacturing some
more slap sticky situations none of the
other animals were exposed to water and
their crates but Gloria had access to
these sea creatures alrighty boys funs
over
don't you want to know what the fun was
the zebra there already knows how to
surf and commune with dolphins or learn
that on the fly out of ways in the sea
creatures live by different rules than
land mammals why can't the dolphins talk
this is seriously out of control it has
been almost 22 seconds since the last
pop-culture reference what could be
worse than San Diego um almost any
American city at least if the weather is
a factor or hyper-intelligent lemurs
with a stereo one of the two Alex turns
in to defend Ike for a second one of the
pilots who crash-landed on Madagascar
only had one CD on his plane
reel-to-reel dooming these lemurs to be
obsessed with reggae fusion house music
from 1993 the Poussin have a caveman
like level of speech while the lemurs
are able to speak as well as the main
characters the zoo sounds may be dumb
but they really know how to prepare a
salad should you have any live people no
Madagascar is a very large island that
is home to over 22 million people I mean
if we had a lot of live people here it
wouldn't be called the wild I would
worry some any context for the wild if
there are no people or how would any of
them know what people are in the first
place maybe this is San Diego after all
you think being a zebra would be a
disadvantage when it comes to building a
shelter but clearly it is not shut up
Spalding not hilarious castaway Wilson
joke is not hilarious Alex conveniently
found all the necessary parts and pieces
to make a statue of liberty while also
being a lion the other hoped animals
we've seen have been able to hold all
the things
Melman is not why are you asked because
do you that's why just so we all
understand each other these boards
spontaneously combusted at what point
does a parent watching this with their
kids decide to just put on an old movie
instead a good quarter of this film is
just references to other films King
Julien is able to use the skeleton hand
as an extension of his own hand this
movie was written by four people and I'm
pretty sure the script was just a bullet
point list of fart sounds and
half-remembered pop-culture references
from the childhood this poor Chris Rock
zebra spends the whole movie talking
about how he wants to live in the wild
and the first thing he does is de missed
the place massive it is impressive he
built a tiki bar in a couple hours
without the use of opposable thumbs or
fingers of any kind
it would have taken days for that
freight ship to get from New York City
to the east coast of Africa when was the
last time any of these animals ate for
it it must be like a week one hour
25-minute movie probably only makes its
run time with bullet like this American
Beauty rose petals stakes poof which
makes less sense for a kids movie than a
Boogie Nights anal in the driveway
parody also associate in Alex a lion
with Kevin Spacey's American Beauty
character tells me ahead of time that
the zebra is gay and hippo is having an
affair with a real-estate agent and to
wrap is West Bentley I guess we'd slash
steak supplier for the record again this
is an homage to a scene in American
Beauty where a middle-aged man is having
a daydream about his daughters teenage
friend the children's movie is a really
weird place for this wait Gasca roll
credits another vine attached to nothing
regular river dancing is bad but river
dancing is worse did they practice this
dance beforehand oh okay
acting like you don't want to do
something then suddenly saying you want
to do it because you really wanted to do
with the whole time cliche this
heretofore totally tame boy and suddenly
has feral instincts just because he's
hungry and the plot needs to jumpstart
excuse me you're biting my butt that's
exactly what my college girlfriend said
to me shortly before dumping me what is
this simple bite on the buttocks among
friends
we'll be backs me up on something I've
been saying for years mr. Alex cannot
stay here he belongs with his own kind
that's racist gotta admit I'm only half
paying attention at this point but are
these two things here walking sticks
with legs and mouths oh hell it's
possible I ingested heroin without
realizing it Oh lion did lion is tricked
into hunting his Central Park Zoo zebra
buddy because honestly I wasn't paying
attention a chop rerun caught my eye for
a moment and when I came back to the
movie that was going on and I felt
compelled to sin it despite my personal
ignorance of course the lion survives
this he's voiced by Ben Stiller you
didn't think such a character was
capable of death did you
these zoo animals learn some hard
lessons about the food chain and while
it's humorous it's still largely filler
for an animated movie with almost zero
plot
now this kind of makes saving him in the
last scene completely pointless also
this movie wants to imply life or death
consequences but only has the balls to
do so via the death of an unimportant
non beloved character Nolan's dreams are
coming true
since it's clear the Penguins can make
things appear out of nowhere why didn't
he summon a more useful writing utensil
like a pen or a pencil so he can't read
but he can write clearly not Alex the
lion is still seeing snakes everywhere
did we ever get a reason on that bull
also why are these steaks so happy about
being eaten in the near future oh oh
great big part of it Alex doesn't
immediately eat Marty what's going on
again I was only out of the room for
however long it takes to be is this the
most forgettable successful animated
movie ever I think it might be the Foo
saws maybe savages but they are really
into their garnishes Alice I'd call this
an Alex the lionex mock in a moment if
the entire freakin movie hadn't been
obviously building to this point all
along are fish not anthropomorphic the
spider was and that's the story of how
alex the Lion decided to slowly starve
to death rather than hurt his friends
yet maybe we could make a few side stops
along the way
he said side stops but when he meant to
say was sequels
you
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes this is your
emergency broadcast system commencing at
the siren any and all crime will be
legal for 12 continuous hours let's go
to eat a damn snack
[Music]
right up my night who are you he is a
friend
[Music]